when people say it's family-friendly
that casinos are not for children this
is an adult resort the city of Macau its
offerings and food and beverage gaming
all of this conventions meeting space
entertainment are pitched for the 21
year old and above there are better
places for kids than Macau or Las Vegas
and in fact less than five percent about
three percent of the visitors Las Vegas
are under 21 and you're trying to
attract more of a what they call a
mass-market
I'm trying to appeal to everybody in the
world and make them say you've got to go
to Macau to stay in this hotel it's the
greatest experience you can imagine that
is the definition of diversification it
isn't just a place for a baccarat player
it's a place for people who want to stay
in beautiful and lovely hotels and be
well served in the sense of the
hospitality industry so you spend more
money on the rooms on the food on the
restaurants and on the meeting
facilities that's diversification it
doesn't mean adding a roller coaster or
a ferris wheel you applied for 280 new
gaming tables at the Wynn Palace and you
ended up getting 150 altogether what was
your reaction we thought that a hundred
was the minimum and we planned
accordingly and we hired accordingly if
you ask a fellow that an executive that
has a hotel that includes gaming room
they will say it's much better to be
under spread in games than over spread
because no one likes to see a bunch of
idle tables it seems as if now times
have obviously changed I mean the
messaging has changed you know coming
from the government and the regulator
they want to clamp down on things a
little bit more they don't want to see
the VIP players as much as they did the
the clamping down as you put it the VIP
section the junket operators shrunk
because the demand went away the
customers went away I don't think that
the government took aim at the junket
operators at least that's not my opinion
that's not the impression I have I think
that the policies of central government
in in Beijing had an effect of reducing
consumer spending at the high-end Louis
vuitton chanel get gaming fell into that
category people with money who were more
who were more aggressive spenders seemed
to have been constrained by the
atmosphere in central government and
that has certainly impacted the amount
of activity that these junket operators
brought to the table and then they've
shrunk and disappeared are we in the
recovery are you seeing signs of a
recovery especially in the mass market
good question
I don't know it's hard to answer that I
think everybody's waiting to see what
impact this has on the market the last
two places that open did not cause the
market to grow did they no well this one
good question we're going to get an
answer to that
in September in October